it just comes down to one thing the
right needs to understand the laws are
meaningless the culture is everything
and the example example I'd like to give
is that you can have a law on the book
like
um you can't protest at an abortion
clinic and you can have another law in
the book you can't protest at a judge's
house but if your culture only enforces
one thing the laws are irrelevant what
are we seeing we had I think 12 or 11 or
12 pro-lifers arrested for protesting at
an abortion clinic none of the
protesters protesters at the judge's
house got arrested that's a cultural
problem I don't think that the laws are
irrelevant but I think I would agree
with you that the culture is more
important I do think that the culture
war is it needs to happen and we need to
be at the foreign
if this whole country all completely
agreed on cultural issues you would have
no crime yeah true but but because they
don't know about that I'm not I don't
mean quite literally I mean for the most
part crime would be dramatically gone